R
WATCHING, SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.
♪ ♪
TREY: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, I AM TREY GOWDY, IT'S
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
BORDER SECURITY AND
IMMIGRATION ARE FEDERAL
ISSUES, IMMIGRATION IS
MENTIONED IN THE
CONSTITUTION, 17 STATES
SHARE A BORDER WITH ANOTHER
COUNTRY, WE CAN'T HAVE 50
DIFFERENT IMMIGRATION POLICY
AND 17 DIFFERENT APPROACHES
TO BORDER SECURITY.
BUT WHAT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ISN'T DOING ITS
JOB.
WHAT IS THE BORDER ISN'T
SECURE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T FOLLOW
ITS OWN LAWS, IT IS
SMUGGLERS, AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND DRUGS AND
WEAPONS AND TERRORISM ALSO
PEOPLE HERE UNLAWFULLY
COMMITTING SERIOUSLY, DEADLY
CRIMES, SOVEREIGN NATIONS
NEED SECURE BORDERS.
STRONG COUNTRIES ENFORCE
THEIR LAW ANDS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO ITS
JOB OR SOMEONE ELSE WILL.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND RON
DESANTIS ARE HIGHLIGHTING
THESE ISSUES, THERE ARE NOW
THREATS TO SUE GOVERNORS AND
CALLS FOR CRIMINAL PROBES.
SOMEONE REMOVED GOVERNORS
FROM OFFICE BUT NOT REMOVE